notre enjeu qui touche beaucoup les gens
la gestion de l'offre les agriculteurs
qui veulent un engagement qu'ils
allaient protéger l'intégralité de la
gestion de l'offre seulement la gestion
de l'offre en général mais vraiment son
intégralité est ce que vous engagez à ça
pour garder ça dans son ensemble c'est
une négociation avec onze pays où tous
les enjeux économiques sont sur la table
tous les secteurs économie on s'engage à
protéger la gestion de l'offre et on va
la protéger jusqu'au bout mada c'est ce
qu'on fait depuis 2006 se promener
s'engage à ça mais on le fait depuis le
début
l'intégralité de la gestion de la
gestion boeuf en indiquant protégerait
la gestion